weniger kontakte mehr quarantäne
bund und länder streiten und weitere
corona maßnahmen masten oder geteilte
klassen die schulen geraten in den fokus
der korona bekämpfung gemeinsame regeln
werden aber noch nicht vereinbart
europa vor der zerreißprobe ungarn und
polen blockieren den eu haushalt und
damit hunderte milliarden euro helfen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten zu beginn einer
neuen woche zusammen mit norbert lehmann
für den sport einen guten anteil von mir
zwei wochen ist es her dass die
bundesregierung auf den exponentiellen
anstieg der korona zahlen reagiert und
der soziale leben in deutschland weiter
eingeschränkt hat erstmal nur im
november doch zur halbzeit sieht es
nicht nach entspannung aus also berät
bundeskanzlerin merkel heute wieder mit
minister präsidenten und präsidentinnen
darüber wie es weitergehen soll
seit fünf stunden läuft die konferenz
überwiegend per video und es sind wohl
ausgesprochen schwierige gespräche
streit gibt es offenbar über maßnahmen
die vor allem der bund einführen wollte
neue verpflichtende kontakt
beschränkungen regeln an schulen und
eine quarantäne für alle menschen mit
erkältungssymptomen andreas huppert hat
diesen schwierigen tag in berlin für uns
beobachtet als kurz vor 14 uhr heute
nachmittag bayerns ministerpräsident
söder und berlins regierender
bürgermeister müller ins kanzleramt
kommen ist schon klar es wird eine
kontroverse diskussion werden um der
pandemie herr zu werden hatte nämlich
allen voran das kanzleramt auf weitere
schärfere kontakt beschränkungen
bestanden auch bayern könnte sich das
vorstellen
wir sind ja im moment im zeitplan
zunächst man mit den bisherigen
maßnahmen und sie zeigen auch schon
erste erfolge das kann man schon sehen
also dass ganz steile wachstum ist
abgebremst ich befürchte dass es aber
nicht gereicht
in anderen bundesländern regte sich
widerstand die wollten mehr
freiwilligkeit zb bei der frage wie und
in welchem umfang man privat feiert auch
dass kinder und jugendliche sich künftig
ausschließlich nur mit einem einzigen
spielkameraden sollten treffen dürfen
ist stark umstritten
die opposition im bundestag nimmt dieses
ansinnen weltfremd sie treffen sich in
ihren klassen in den schulräumen auf der
anfahrt in den bussen und straßenbahnen
aber außerhalb dieses komplexes sollen
sie sich nur mit einer weiteren person
treffen
das ist nicht logisch
das geht vollkommen an der
lebensrealität von kindern vorbei das
geht an der lebensrealität von ganz ganz
vielen familien vorbei fdp und afd gehen
mit den bislang bekannt gewordenen
vorschlägen von bund und ländern ebenso
hart ins gericht pandemie bekämpfung hin
oder her wir leben das grundsätzlich ab
diesen diesen eingriff in die
privatsphäre
und wir werden einen demokratischen
mitteln versuchen das zu verhindern ich
kann die bundeskanzlerin und das
bundeskanzleramt nur auffordern künftig
mit maximaler transparenz und
umfassender begründung den deutschen zu
erklären welche maßnahmen man aus
welchem grund für erforderlich hält
appelle statt verbote das scheint die
devise
noch ist nicht klar auf welche linie man
sich verständigen wird klar nur in genau
einer woche werden sie sich wieder
treffen dann kommen die anti corona
maßnahmen erneut auf den prüfstand von
bund und ländern also noch alles im
fluss schack unterlagen sie in berlin
womit müssen wir rechnen gibt es weitere
verschärfungen also das halte ich für
ausgeschlossen dass heute tatsächlich
noch mal verschärfungen dabei rauskommen
denn das ist einer der gründe warum
diese sitze und jetzt so lange dauert
wir haben mehrere beschlussvorlagen
heute gesehen die erste von der
bundesregierung in der also da drin
stand was sich die bundesregierung gerne
wünscht an weiteren maßnahmen und dann
folgten mehrere überarbeitungen den
letzten nehme die letzte die wir gesehen
haben kam von den bundesländern und die
haben eben da eine große streichliste
drin gehabt da wurde dann zum beispiel
aus den kontakt beschränkungen außerhalb
des hauses die eigentlich mit sanktionen
belegt werden sollten nur noch ein
appell auch die quarantäne bei
erkältungssymptomen müsste raus
gestrichen werden wenn sich die länder
durchsetzen
also da scheint es wirklich sehr viel
redebedarf zu geben und die entscheidung
über die schulen die wurde ja sowieso
schon vertagt also eine verschärfung
heute in wesentlichem umfang sehe ich da
nicht kommen es gab bei dem treffen
heute nachmittag wohl heftige
auseinandersetzungen wie man hört also
noch haben wir keine live-berichte
sozusagen aus der aus der sitzung aber
man sieht es eben an den unterlagen die
wir hier einsehen können so viel
rot durchgestrichen ist im text das ist
schon bemerkenswert zumal man sich ja in
erinnerung rufen muss dass wir damit
gerechnet haben dass es heute eigentlich
nur eine bestandsaufnahme geben wird was
wir hier sehen ist dass der bund wieder
verließ stärker für härtere maßnahmen
sich einsetzt als die länder
das hatten wir bei den letzten treffen
auch immer schon gesehen dass angela
merkel und ihre mitstreiter da zu
härteren maßnahmen bereit gewesen wären
und dass die bundesländer dann nicht
mitgezogen haben jetzt müssen wir
abwarten wie der beschluss am ende
aussieht dann werden wir sehen wo
tatsächlich die gräben liegen
ja sobald sich etwas ergibt schalten wir
gleich wieder zu ihnen chuck und täler
bis dahin schon mal herzlichen dank über
das bund und länder treffen berichten
wir ausführlich in einem zdf spezial im
anschluss an diese sendung mokoena auf
dem rückzug ist und in welchen
landkreisen die zahlen weiter steigen
können sie tagesaktuell in der zdf-
heute- app nachschauen
wir schauen auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen die ligen montags in der regel
niedriger als an anderen wochentagen
weil nicht alle gesundheitsämter daten
übermittelt haben
das robert koch institut meldet zehn
1824 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
vor einer woche waren es 13 1363 im 7
tagesschnitt haben sich täglich 17.000
190 menschen angesteckt viele eltern
fragen sich ob die hygiene konzepte in
den schulen ausreichend über distanz
unterricht klasseneinteilungen oder eine
generelle masken pflicht im unterricht
diskutiert deshalb die politik
entscheidungen wurden vertagt
insgesamt haben sich 18 1298 schüler
also 0,17 prozent angesteckt 3798 lehrer
sind infiziert das sind 0,42 prozent im
verhältnis haben sich also deutlich mehr
lehrer als schüler angesteckt bislang
mussten aber nur wenige schulen komplett
zu machen
teilweise geschlossen sind hingegen etwa
14 prozent der schulen henry
unter corona bedingungen wäre das hier
eine ideale konstellation wenige schüler
ein lehrer ausreichend abstand
so saß hier schon mal vor den ferien aus
die klassen halbiert die hälfte der
schüler blieb zu hause im täglichen
wechsel leer
es lief nicht gut also wenn dann so ein
leistungs gefüge da entsteht das dann
für schüler fehlen die auch hier
mithelfen am unterricht
johanna mitschülern helfen es ist gehört
dazu zusammen zu lernen für mich weil so
lerne ich besser ich kann das ja auch
anderen erklären und das hilft mir ja
auch beim lernen und das kann ich zu
hause nicht unbedingt die schule liegt
in einem hamburger problemstadtteil
bildungschancen hier haben viele schüler
nur in der schule
manche haben kein internet zu hause die
eltern sind oft überlastet und die
lehrer können sich nicht teilen
wenn wir schulen offen lassen möchten
dann müssen wir es schlichtweg wollen
dann müssen wir alle sagen wir
verzichten auf viele andere sachen weil
schule bildung ein so hohes gut hat und
zwar für alle kinder auch für die in den
schwachen stadtteilen auch das haben
schüler und lehrer in der ersten phase
des wechsel unterrichtes gelernt reines
lernen ist das eine persönliche kontakte
aber sind genauso wichtig es geht um
motivation es geht darum zu sehen dass
man nicht alleine ist es geht darum
unterstützung von gleichaltrigen zu
bekommen
und es geht auch einfach um soziale
entwicklung die wegfallen die ganz
besonders in der pubertät eine wichtige
rolle spielen
und das heißt aber auch schule muss für
alle offen bleiben mit geöffneten
fenstern maske und viel draußen pausen
quarantäne fälle und vereinzelte
schulschließungen inklusive wie schnell
die krone maßnahmen ganze existenzen in
gefahr bringen können
das weiß die gastronomiebranche noch aus
dem früher als restaurants cafés und
bars zum ersten mal schließen mussten
brach der umsatz um rund 40 prozent ein
und die zahl der beschäftigten etwa in
kneipen um fast 35 prozent
jetzt also wieder alles zu und die
regierung verspricht betroffene bekommen
75 prozent ihrer einnahmen vom letzten
november
doch so schnell geht es nicht für viele
oft sei es eng werden susan von lojewski
in stuttgart ist er nur der harry
heribert meyers betreibt in der
landeshauptstadt eine kult kneipe die
schnitzel sind legendär
seit 25 jahren ist er wird aus
leidenschaft jetzt sind alle elf
mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit die aushilfen
entlassen
die überbrückungshilfe für den november
erwartet harry dringend dabei sollte es
schnell und unbürokratisch gehen ich
habe jetzt mit beim steuerberater ist
nunmal kurzschlüssen und er meinte also
es gibt bisher keine möglichkeit und
wieder formulare herunterzuladen oder
gelder zu beantragen und so musste zeit
mal abwarten frühestens in neun tagen
können die anträge gestellt werden
zeit die hiesigen gül nicht hat der 45
jährige besitzt drei restaurants in
bester stuttgarter lage hat allein
30.000 euro fixkosten im monat alle
reserven sind aufgebraucht
heute ist die ente sind immer noch nicht
da aber unsere kosten sind da wir müssen
bezahlen über 40 prozent sind die
umsätze in der gastroszene zwischen märz
und august eingebrochen mit dem teil
shutdown im november wurde ihr vom bund
75 prozent des letztjährigen november
umsatzes versprochen geld das aber noch
nicht fließt müssen schnell nachlegen
und es muss zu einer sofortigen
auszahlung kommen
und das kann nicht erst im neuen jahr
passieren das muss umgehend und schnell
und vor allem auch unbürokratisch direkt
erfolgen wird harry meyers rechnet auch
im dezember mit einer schließung der
lokale für viele seiner kollegen so
meint er könne dass das aus bedeuten
auf der suche nach einem geeigneten
impfstoff haben heute die amerikaner
einen erfolg vermeldet der us-konzern
moderner teilte mit sein neu
entwickelter corona impfstoff habe eine
wirksamkeit von 94,5 prozent moderner
verfolgt einen ähnlichen weg wie bei
montech und weise die mit ihrem
impfstoff eine schutzwirkung von 90
prozent bescheinigen mit biontech und
weise hat die eu eine liefervertrag
geschlossen und auch mit moderner wird
verhandelt
italien ist ja eines der länder das im
frühjahr sehr früh und sehr hart von
corona getroffen wurde und mit der
regierten ausgangs beschränkung in
europa reagierte die zahlen
stabilisierten sich im laufe der zeit
nun ist die lage wieder verheerend rund
30.000 neue corona infektionen pro tag
zählen die behörden im norden italiens
in südtirol schwinden damit die
hoffnungen auf die so dringend
benötigten winterurlauber annette hessen
weg seit heute sind selbst grundschulen
geschlossenen südtirol die brüder felix
fritz und frank engel spielen jetzt
nicht nur gemeinsam zu hause auch ihr
schulunterricht findet jetzt hier statt
online am computer
südtirol ist weitgehend dem lockdown
vater stefan engel ist froh im home
office arbeiten zu können
wenn die eltern berufstätig sind im büro
in der werkstatt auf der baustelle und
dann ist natürlich die schließung von
schulen ein gravierendes problem weil
man natürlich nicht weiß wohin mit den
kindern
im skiort speikboden laufen trotz rote
zone
die vorbereitungen für die wintersaison
beim skiverleih egon gruber haben sie
die bretter top in schuss gebracht und
fürchten doch dass es die korona lage
bis zum saisonstart anfang dezember
nicht bessert wir haben viele
mitarbeiter wir haben ein großes
skigebiet
die folgen sind natürlich schwerwiegend
wenn wir es nicht öffnen könnten
wir versuchen natürlich das beste und
hoffen das beste um den geltenden locker
und möglichst kurz zu halten plant die
südtiroler regierung jetzt einen
massentest positive vor allem die ohne
symptome sollen entdeckt und die
infektions kurve so nach unten gedrückt
werden damit wir zunächst einmal die
schulen wieder öffnen können das ist das
erste ziel die wirtschaftlichen
aktivitäten langsam wieder in gang
bringen
in bezug auf die wintersaison hängt das
nicht allein von unseren zahlen habe das
hängt dann davon ab wie es in ganz
europa aussieht auch in den
herkunftsländern touristen
in den bergen warten sie ab noch hoffen
sie auf eine winter ski saison auf
touristen besonders schwer getroffene
länder wie italien sollen auch dank
europäischer finanzhilfen durch die
pandemie kommen eigentlich seit dem
sommer schon beschlossene sache doch
jetzt tobt darüber ein handfester krach
ungarn und polen wollen den corona
aufbau von über 750 milliarden euro
blockieren und darüber hinaus auch noch
den gesamten eu haushalt für die
nächsten sieben jahre
hintergrund die eu will alle
haushaltsgelder grundsätzlich nur noch
an länder zahlen die sich an
rechtsstaatliche regeln halten
ja da müssen wir gleich mal bei in
brüssel bei anne gellinek nachfragen was
hat dieses veto von ungarn und polen
denn nun für folgen für die eu
die erste folge ist dass die weiter
verhandlungen über den siebenjährigen eu
haushalt und den milliardenschweren
corona hilfstopf erst mal blockiert sind
und das könnte bedeuten dass eben die
dringend erwarteten gelder für die
besonders betroffenen länder wie italien
und spanien sich weiter verzögern
könnten genau darauf setzt viktor orban
er spielt auf zeit sein ziel ist es den
rechtsstaats mechanismus ganz aus dem
haushaltspaket herauszulösen und in
irgendwann mal später zu verhandeln das
aber scheint mit vielen westeuropäischen
und nordeuropäischen regierungschefs und
dem europaparlament nicht zu machen
also richten sich jetzt alle augen auf
angela merkel sie ist die
regierungschefin des land ist dass
gerade die eu ratspräsidentschaft
innehat schon schon am donnerstag wird
sie versuchen müssten mit ungarn und
polen einen kompromiss zu finden denn
dann haben sich die eu staats und
regierungschefs zu einer schalte
zusammen verabredet über die bekämpfung
der korona pandemie dieses treffen wird
nun zu einem krisen haushalts gipfel
die erklärung von anne gellinek vielen
dank nach brüssel und wir schalten jetzt
noch mal nach berlin so schack und aller
banerjee über das ministerpräsidentin
der bundeskanzlerin mit den treffen mit
den ministerpräsidenten und präsidenten
gibt es denn inzwischen ergebnisse zu
vermelden konnte das ist scheint sich
zumindest ein ende abzuzeichnen wir
haben ja hier immer den blick auf die
pressekonferenz auf den raum und die
kollegen sammeln sich jetzt dort wieder
es scheint so zu sein dass die sitzung
zu ende geht noch ist kein ergebnis
bekannt ich glaube was wir erwarten
können ist dass sie beim gemeinsamen
ziel bleiben die streit die zahlen
wieder runter zu bekommen nämlich auf 50
pro 100000 pro sieben tage
neuansteckungen maximal dass es ein
gemeinsames ziel gewesen was die ganze
zeit nicht gewackelt hat und wir rechnen
jetzt also in den nächsten minuten damit
dass die pressekonferenz hier los geht
und für die ergebnisse im detail
erfahren
dann schalten wir sofort wieder zu ihnen
vielen dank und hella und damit sind wir
schon beim sport und nun zu dir gott und
zum nächsten spiel der dfb elf morgens
ja genau
und da würde ja sogar ein unentschieden
schon reichen zum gruppensieg aber ein
sieg gegen spanien das wäre ein
prestige-erfolg und ein gelungener
abschluss eines schwierigen
fußballjahres bei dem es am ende ein
paar störgeräusche zwischen trainer löw
und direktor bierhoff gibt der zeitpunkt
überrascht
löw muss kurz vor dem wegweisenden spiel
fragen zu seiner zukunft beantworten das
hat er oliver bierhoff zu verdanken der
seinen coach in einem interview mit der
faz unter druck setzt den weg den der
bundestrainer eingeschlagen hat gehe ich
bis einschließlich der em mit heißluft
hat nur bis zum nächsten turnier die
volle rückendeckung
also von daher ist da jetzt kein
gesprächsbedarf aufgrund eines
interviews wollen die rolle von ich ein
großes vertrauensverhältnis wenn das so
gesagt hat dann ist natürlich so klar es
ist ja immer von einem turnier abhängig
wie es weitergeht toni kroos ist nach
gelbsperre wieder dabei und kapitän
manuel neuer wird seinen 96 das
länderspiel bestreiten damit der
deutschen tor rekord von sepp maier
knacken
zwei spieler der ukrainischen
nationalmannschaft die am samstag in
leipzig gegen die dfb elf antraten sind
heute positiv auf kroner getestet worden
bei den deutschen spielern so
bundestrainer löw sein gestern heute
alle tests negativ ausgefallen
die wegen der korona pandemie auf den
sommer 2021 verlegt und olympischen
spiele in tokio sollen wie geplant
ausgetragen werden und zwar mit
zuschauern
das bekräftigten heutige us chef bach
und der japanische ministerpräsident
sogar fast 3000 einwohner pro
quadratkilometer
das in tokio wirklich die olympischen
spiele stattfinden sollen ist kaum
vorstellbar
der olympische funke aber überträgt sich
bei ioc präsident bach und japans
premier superuser ide aus respekt vor
dem japanischen volk beteuerte bach
werde alles getan um die spiele
auszurichten das ioc werde sich an den
kosten für impfungen beteiligen und er
sei sich sicher dass auch zuschauer
zugelassen werden können so bach
aussagen in diesen zeiten die
befremdlich wirken für olympische spiele
in dieser stadt sind ja noch acht monate
bis zum beginn kann noch viel passieren
auch positive ebenso nur dann alle
geimpft und dann läuft es doch bereits
in gottes ohr legen und sonnenschein ist
für morgen angesagt die details gleich
beim wetter von es denn terry
das war es von uns für den moment mehr
zur corona lage in deutschland und dann
auch vielleicht die die pressekonferenz
mit der bundeskanzlerin gleich im
anschluss in unserem spezial ihnen
vielen dank für ihr interesse einen
schönen abend und auf ein wiedersehen
morgen um 19 uhr
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter dieses hoch hier
auf dem atlantik das dehnt sich
allmählich aus richtung osten und bringt
uns allmählich sonniges wetter aber im
norden gibt es noch regen und der
verabschiedet sich morgen tagesverlauf
ostwärts im osten regnet es in der nacht
das wird langsam weniger und zieht
ostwärts auch ab ansonsten kommt neuer
regen von westen auf im südwesten bildet
sich nebel bei temperaturen von null
grad am alpenrand und 9 grad am
niederrhein
morgen im tagesverlauf also im norden
viele wolken und auch regen das wandert
allmählich nach osten und aus dem
südwesten her kommt kräftiger wind auf
teils stürmisch ganz im südwesten
deutschlands wiederum zeigt sich die
sonne hier macht sich der
hochdruckeinfluss schon bemerkbar
temperaturen erreichen dabei elf grad am
alpenrand 9 grad im vogtland und 14 grad
am niederrhein
in den kommenden tagen wird es
allmählich wechselhafter werden mittwoch
noch viel sonne scheint sehr mild bis 16
grad am donnerstag kommt regen dazu und
am freitag gibt es mal normale
temperaturen für november bei werten
zwischen 2 und 8 grad
ein schöner abend